We will now like to begin
our analysis of motion.
And we'll start with
one dimensional motion.
Let's just consider a
person running along a road.
And so here's our runner,
and here's our road.
And what we want to do
is be able to describe
the position, the velocity, the
acceleration of this runner.
In order to do that, we need
our first mathematical tool,
which is a coordinate system.
What is a coordinate system?
Well, the first thing that we
want to choose is an origin.
We can pick the origin
anywhere we want.
That's a degree of freedom.
So let's choose a point
along our road as our origin.
The next thing to do
is to choose an axis.
Well, the road is
naturally defining
an axis for our problem.
And so we'll call
this the x-axis.
Now, along with
that axis, we want
to divide that up into
some type of units
so we might divide
our axis like this.
And what's important
here is to introduce
a positive coordinate direction.
And so the way I'll do that,
is I'll call this the plus x,
and on this side of the
origin x is negative.
Now, the third most
important thing
is that we're going to talk
about vectors and physics.
So we want a choice
of unit vector.
Now, because it's only
one dimensional motion,
we only need one unit vector.
So what that means is a choice
of unit vector at every point.
Let's just consider
a point here, P1.
So our unit vector
I'll call it i hat 1.
Now, let's pick
another point here.
We'll call this the point P2.
And over here we'll choose
a unit vector, i hat 2.
So every single point in
space has a unit vector.
Now, what's unique
about this one
dimensional linear
Cartesian coordinate
system is the following,
these unit vectors
have the same magnitude--
a unit vector by definition
has magnitude 1-- and they're
pointing in the same direction.
So if two vectors have
the same magnitude
and point in the same
direction, they are equal.
So what makes this
coordinate system unique,
this Cartesian
coordinate system,
that every single point,
no matter where we are,
the unit vectors point
in the positive direction
because they have the same
magnitude and direction.
All of these unit
vectors are equal.
And we call that i hat.
So symbolically, we
may draw a picture
and indicate our unit vector
in the positive x direction.
And this is our
coordinate system.
And we can next
begin to describe
the position and the
velocity of our object
as it's moving along
this x direction.